okay this question is from andy from
that ufo podcast thanks to the three of
you and what more needs to be done to
encourage those in the mainstream to get
involved with data collection
hello so we'll start with sean
well that's frankly that's what i'm
working on every day it's um it's
cutting the nonsense we've been frankly
complaining and borderline ranting about
on this on this podcast cutting it out
not entertaining it anymore
um not even frankly i don't care go
start your own show
you know what i mean um you want to find
out all the secrets of the various
universe go for it we want to collect
data
and so we talk to people we as i as i
often say we say this is real
here are some excellent data points to
look at
what are your thoughts do you see merit
here they say yes i see merit would you
like to help us collect more data and
try to understand this these are i mean
i'm presenting this in a very vague
fashion but it's that simple
hey can i have your attention
this is real would you like to get
involved yes you know yes or no some
people have said no
they said you know what we've already
we're already in a good place we have
good contracts here we're in a place
like this we don't want to mess with our
you know we don't want to spook our
clientele
or our investors or or whatever it is
and it's understandable but some people
see this for what it is
that for some something's different i
don't i don't i've never liked the
question why now i don't know
now i'm i only have now as i said
earlier in our conversation um
but it's interesting
um and so i you know i hope that slices
luke
yeah can you um i want to be accurate as
possible can you repeat the question
please um
you want to know what people could do to
uh to encourage data collection in the
private sector
at a higher level
[Applause]
i mean it's a tough question because i
mean
i would say anything people can do is is
helpful but then again
that's not entirely true every time
because
not everything is helpful
um
you know i i think
i think being aware of the conversation
um you know everybody now has one of
these devices in their hands right so
your your virtual collection platform
taking videos pictures and whatnot
um
i think being informed
um arming yourself with knowledge and
information um and yes that it may seem
contradictory but it requires um
talking to people you know and
and by the way formulating your own
opinions as a result of that okay don't
don't take somebody else's opinions
um and understanding the the playing
field you know who who who's legitimate
who's not what are the motivations and
and
by by certain organizations and people
that may be involved in this topic why
do some people uh have the opinions that
they do you know uh
maybe
you know it it's hard for me to say
because
you're asking people to teach themselves
and they say okay well teach me how to
teach myself well
then again if i do that then we fall
into the same you know pit we did last
time while teaching you what to think
and not how to think and so
um i don't want to be overly
prescriptive just be curious be yourself
ask the questions
it's okay to ask the questions
i think
be fearless in your pursuit of knowledge
and and also have the courage to
question
um
question people including myself
including sean including you including
everybody
um
questions aren't bad um questioning is
is good now uh
disrespect and attacks now that's that's
not um you know that's that's not that's
not ever
something that should be should be
supported or condoned
sadly it is